on poursuit cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie Gabriel qu'est-ce que
vous nous avez concocté ce soir et bien
Mathilde on commence avec un rendez-vous
musical le concours de chant yvelinois
le tremplin des voix revient pour une 9e
édition proposée par l'association la
voix en scène vous pouvez venir assister
aux auditions de ses futurs talents
après la préssélection des candidats ce
weekend ont lieu les auditions devant le
jury et le show est ouvert au public
depuis plusieurs années le concours du
tremplin des voies apporte un
accompagnement personnalisé aux artistes
tout en leur donnant l'opportunité de
faire de la scène pour les découvrir des
places sont encore disponibles sur le
site du trempelin des vois et ce weekend
c'est aussi le retour des Ludy days oui
des samedis et jusqu'au 25 novembre les
passionnés de jeux ont rendez-vous dans
le réseau des médiiathèques de
Saint-Quentin en evelim au programme une
semaine consacrée aux jeux de société
mais aussi jeux de plateau escape game
ou encore jeux vidéo des animations
seront également organisées notamment
par des associations de jeux linoise
l'événement est gratuit et ouvert à tous
on va prendre un peu de hauteur à
présent avec un spectacle
d'aéromodélisme oui alors l'association
modélisme et loisirs techniques vous
propose un spectacle aérien d'intérieur
au total une trentaine de pilotes feront
voler des reproductions d'une
cinquantaine d'avions parfois avoisinant
jusqu'à 2 m vous retrouverez des avions
de différentes époques mais aussi une
escadrie à l'effigie des Jeux Olympiques
pour assister au spectacle rendez-vous
dimanche après-midi au gymnase du levent
de Fontenel le fleu et on parlera
modélisme avec nos invités également et
oui d'ailleurs ils sont en plateau avec
nous on continue vos idées de sorti
Gabriel avec un rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer à poissi pour les gourmands oui
les producteurs du salon vin et saveur
vous donnent rendez-vous ce weekend pour
la 12e édition du salon durant de jours
vous allez pouvoir aller à la rencontre
des producteurs locaux de toute la
France mais aussi bien sûr des ivlines
venus présenter leur production parmi
eux charcutiers traiteurs brasseurs ou
encore ignneron de quoi vous donner
peut-être quelques idées de produits à
mettre sur votre table à Noël Mathilde
vous allez faire un tour Gabriel je je
pense que ça peut être une bonne idée je
pense aussi en tout cas noël approche à
grand pas vous l'avez dit alors pourquoi
pas commencer à rêver dès maintenant
avec un spectacle façon Broadway oui
dans cette représentation les artistes
reviennent sur les plus belles pages de
la comédie musicale américaine parmi
elles certaines rendu célèbre comme Moon
River dans breakfast at Tiffany avec
Audrey hebburn qui a valu un un Oscar au
compositeur celui de la meilleure
musique de film sur scène pour
interpréter ses œuvres un trio
d'artistes qui reexplore cette univers
né dans les années folles le concert il
a lieu dimanche Mathilde au château de
Buc et on termine avec du sport et un
match
important oui ce sera le match à ne pas
louper ce weekend dans les iivlines en
Coupe de France où qui évolue en
Régionale 1 va affronter anger un club
de Ligue 2 ça se passe ce samedi à 14h
ce 7e tour de la Coupe de France devrait
tiré plus de 200 personnes 2000
personnes pardon sur place des places
seront en vente le jour du match à la
billetterie oui est le dernier
représentant des iines dans cette
compétition et on leur souhaite bonne
chance bien sûr même si le match
s'annonce très compliqué face à Angers
merci beaucoup Gabriel pour toutes ces
idées de sortie